tonight john is honoring his friends and
fellow parents gabrielle union and
dwyane wade
together they have set a powerful
example for parents to be good allies to
young people
who are figuring out who they are the
couple has been vocal in supporting
their transgender daughter
ziya's journey and they're just two of
time magazine's most influential people
of 2020. thank you time for including us
in this very special evening
e.t has an exclusive preview of previous
recipients harry and meghan markle
along with their dog poola helping to
announce this year's list on tonight's
star-studded time 100 special honorees
include
jennifer hudson and megan the stallion
but in the message from the duke and
duchess of sussex
it kind of sounds like they're talking
about themselves amid a war with the
press
what we're exposed to online seeps into
how we engage with each other offline
it can train us to be kind or it can
train us to be cruel
but when the bad outweighs the good it
erodes our ability to have compassion
and our ability to put ourselves in
someone else's shoes